Oh
[Music]
[Music]
what
[Music]
families
and breeze I ripped my suit I ripped my
suit
fine
do the reaction by myself
[Music]
what's going on reject nation Greg Alva
here and I'm John Andrew Gordon from the
movie source channel it is 5:30 in the
morning John and I pulled an all-nighter
hope you enjoyed that sketch special
thanks to my lovely lady Olivia she
really helped out a crap-ton on that
video and special thank you to Brad
Lambert for a good tip on how to end the
video too so thanks Brad so what we're
gonna do today is we're gonna we're
gonna check out the chair we're gonna do
the reaction for it we're probably gonna
watch it twice honestly cuz it's the
frickin infinity war trade we're gonna
do a separate video where we actually
analyze the trailer Cassandra we're
shouting you out my dear patron of the
day shout out you earned it and make
sure to download and follow us on the
startups at people let's do it let's do
it oh my god guys it's happening
to see if we could become something whoa
so when they need us we can fight the
battles okay I like your haircut
I did not see the leash trailer
[Music]
oh mighty sense
[Music]
[Music]
still alive better
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
damn
[Music]
they just show that
[Music]
my god
[Music]
oh we gotta watch it again
you know you know we're gonna watch this
like fireball there was definitely a lot
there was definitely a lot of Avengers
one callbacks in there with the music
and the line they're like oh yeah the
beginning was the exact same lines
humming very complete circle I love it
and I love the vestry music yeah they
just show you about I mean we all
predicted the thing with vision was she
showed that in the trailers well I mean
we all knew it's gonna be right for them
to actually show it but it I think it's
just I think you know to show us like
the danger looming like yeah for real
hey maybe he'll wriggle out of that one
only for it to happen
there was an idea Nick you're together
remarkable people just dr. strange finds
false teeth we could become that's crazy
I would love that I love that at Albany
yes
looks like the Milan who fight the
battles I like your haircut
for the most part seriously this is the
good list it's like titles of Enders
music
[Music]
which this needs to be seen on IMAX
Dustin's tesseract
people just really like Johnny looks
much better if he looks much more real
yeah
[Music]
the guy with my brainy begonia
[Music]
and it's look so like
[Music]
epic
[Music]
I can't wait for that scene I can't wait
for that scene oh my god I can't wait
for that scene Oh I mean okay we're just
gonna give super quick thoughtful actual
trailer review on a separate video I'm
very excited this looks like it's really
gonna deliver all the goods it is
incredibly epic and first even though
it's just a trailer I get the strong
impression this is gonna be a pretty
balanced film these guys did civil war
and as our silly and Winter Soldier but
Civil War had a lot of characters and
that was very well-balanced and they're
really a being up there directing level
here would take and the cinematography
looks different than Winter Soldier and
Civil War
oh yeah yeah huge I mean everything I
really like the way they're shooting
this and it does feel like a different
kind of movie and it does feel like a
culmination it feels like a war and it
feels like the way the trailer is
structured it has that Bill you know
yeah see everybody was gonna come
together and then you see just what this
battles gonna look like at the outset
you know yeah this isn't just a one part
movie you know so this is like I bet
we're gonna see the real power and
threat of not only Thanos with the chaos
that Thanos is gonna bring in as yeah I
think just you know bouncing off what
you said I think the thing I appreciate
the most besides all the fanboy moments
we're like that were amazing was you
know seeing the threat level and seeing
the the Avengers actually being in
danger and like seeing action getting
until the danger yeah oh really I'm like
how are they supposed to win this
impossible situation cuz it really looks
impossible and Fanus putting on the
Infinity stuff like as he's starting to
put them on like and seeing uh I believe
we saw Proxima midnight throwing a her
spirit Nomad there or Captain America
whoever he is there but that looked
amazing and like just again seeing the
you know characters like from the Black
Order that we're gonna see having some
personality it's gonna be interesting to
see characters with a threat level where
they've got powers similar and even more
powerful than the actual Avengers than
to see them mowing through like armies
and stuff so I'm gonna be really
interested in seeing you know them go
through bad guys who actually have
personalities and actually have
stories like that's gonna be interesting
to see in my opinion this looks like
it's gonna be very rewarding a lot of
the gray I love that this trailer didn't
take time to show you a shot of every
single one of them yeah you mean you
show them all divided and they're
starting to come together
that was great thank - is that this
trailer really delivered to me every
level and like it looks intense but it
also looks heroic and also looks fun and
it also looks kind of badass yeah it
looks like it's have everything
everything yeah and and the the ruse is
like these are the guys you brought you
you me and Dupree okay
and of course patron today shoutout for
wrapping up this video Cassandra your
mother is one of the best women we've
ever known as like she's the lady Stark
of the patronage XE specifically asks us
to give you a shout out for infinity war
as part of her patron pledge and
Cassandra you are such a sweet little
girl I remember seeing your reaction to
us giving you know you a mention in a
video once and you were so adorable I
mean you in person your place you're
just an adorable little girl I'm so
happy to know your family and to know
you guys and to know that you prefer me
over John yeah yeah the best feeling a
man can ask for when every female even
female animals prefer Jon over me listen
guys keep a look out for our trailer
analysis subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell you can
follow us on the Stardust app follow us
immediately and more importantly make
sure to check out Andrew Gordon on the
movie source channel he does a lot of
fantastic videos a lot of great analysis
and breakdowns go check it out as soon
as you can and leave a comment what do
you think of the infinity war trailer do
you think it's gonna live up to the hype
we most certainly do talk to you guys in
a bit